hello and welcome to this video playing
FM Elias is it alias Elias I guess right
okay I've got to my old Indian with f3
don't ya playing it in style of the same
ish variation one of the many setups
that wide can go for against this
opening I'd see what happens yeah maybe
he's some trying to play the night back
and then some Bishop g5
yeah I'm ready for f4 am meeting Bishop
g5 with f4 yeah strategically why does
an excellent shape push up a six Wow
okay now you can go back we should be so
misplaced on a6 I don't minded if he
goes back to see a top lane i th 3f two
or something v6 is just a pretty bad
move because it makes blacks pawn
structure completely inflexible mean it
never wants to go to a 6 ok let's just
grab more space here
so let's see how to develop this now
maybe night to h2 and add 2 F 2 i'm
sorry so night is here so now I've got
the full control over you form it's got
some cowell to play potentially on the
FL maybe on the B file
Gastel should be pretty good for wide
opening up the e4 square
you
386 is ok one now I can take here though
and a half night you for coming if you
mostly porn somewhere on IG form
I take this easier I guess
the only thing that I have to be
cautious with this not to give him very
strong bishop on the long diagonal that
might compensate for being a pawn down
yeah here's an interesting question
between takes I guess TX and Knight
takes rook f8 net it's still not totally
easy to win yeah why did I do that I
come on the key i was thinking Queen
takes rook f1 and I'm attacking myself
but I'm not so sure now check yeah this
is this is the problem if I take and
play Queen c3 he's got rookie too so I
don't have a good movie instead they
said can you believe that have I have a
blunt that this is this stuff okay I
cannot believe this I so should have
taken away the Queen ER Oh Kim king see
one is checking me on f2 and probably
wins takes yeah just losing now check
what a joke
checking them maybe I'm not losing
immediately word how unnecessary is that
check so clean the tool I think I can go
here though
Queen f6 again if I check here and
Queenie for wish I like some serious
come to play I can check here but that
doesn't do much Queen g6 maybe for Queen
e6
check here 27 check at least I've got a
ton of chicks lined up he still has
screen GF 6 cm somehow look at seven
maybe 23 and also not helping
time morning I don't see a winner in
this position I mean I've gotten much
more time but I don't see you in Queens
not going there he threatens to take
this I mean I don't I don't see a move
and I don't have a perpetual I still I
still see a book that I can play okay
now i'm not getting mated i guess what
pretty awful check check check black for
fits on time yeah I mean just I mean I
mean this b6 and so on is just a very
bad way of playing the opening the
position is excellent for Wyatt you the
computer doesn't get it but it is
excellent for white because black has
absolutely no play something this is
just just very very bad him he doesn't
we cannot play c6 cannot play be five if
you press f5 he gives me the e4 square
so the only thing that I have to be
cautious about it's not to give him any
counter play against my king and this is
exactly what happened yeah yeah I'm
controlling me for ok and ok you can
argue i wanted to play some quick move
Sam not get into time pressure again
after you fall bloggers in an inn
swindling mode basically
the engine now is agreeing that white
should win but this is I just have to
take with the Queen this is just not
working check check yeah and here what
is winning here I mean there must be
some kind of winner I don't believe that
I should survive this position the
engine gives Luke g8 I wasn't even sure
that this is not somehow winds and I
didn't see Howard Alice only seems to be
minus one rook g8 though yeah the
threatens check and then Rock g2 now I
computer 1-10 check yeah yeah okay again
check check but still i mean i know i
don't have moves here this is minus five
huh he could have taken on f3 yeah I
didn't see anything against this move
but I couldn't I couldn't prevent it
anymore it was just I was just not a
playable position and Queen takes a
winch four wins for black okay it didn't
have time so Tia was pretty much sure to
win win on time yeah I just got it gave
him far far too much colder play in this
position where I had nice control what
the king was weak and you got to my king
oh my okay thanks for watching